The end of last class,
we started sketching an argument
that comes from Descartes,
the Cartesian argument that says
merely by the process of thinking and the
basis of thought alone attempt to show
that the mind. We all agree
that though our minds, what the,
what the argument attempts to show is
that this mind must be something separate
from my body and what's,
what's amazing about the argument is that
it works on the basis of pure thought
experiment.
The thought experiment you'll recall was
one in which I imagine I tell myself a
story in which what I'm doing
is I'm imagining my mind
existing without my body.
It doesn't seem especially
difficult to do that,
but then we add this extra
philosophical premise.
If I can imagine one
thing without the other,
then it must be that those are two things,
so my mind must not be my body.
My mind must not be the same thing as
my body or way of talking about my body
because of course if my
mind just was tosca bi,
I'm a mom talking about my mind just
was a way of talking about my body.
Then to try to imagine
my mind without my body.
It would be trying to imagine
my body without my body.
That obviously can't happen,
but suppose we try to imagine
a world in which Shelly exists,
but Kagan doesn't. Well, you can't, right?
Because of course there's
just a single thing,
Shelly Kagan and so if you've
imagined Shelly existing,
then of course you're
imagining that single thing.
Shelly Kagan existing and if you
imagine nene Kagan not existing,
then you're imagining that single thing.
Shelly Kagan not existing,
so you can't even imagine a world in
which Shelly exists, but Kagan doesn't.
Now it's important not to
be confused about this.
We can easily imagine a
world in which you know,
I don't have the last name Kagan
or perhaps to switch it around.
Shelly's not my name.
Supposedly my parents had named me Bruce.
Nothing would be easier.
Imagine a world in which Kagan exists,
but Shelly doesn't exist because
nobody in the world, his name's Shelly.
The question is not,
can you imagine me with a different name,
Bruce instead of Shelly.
Easy enough. It's rather,
can you imagine a world in which the very
thing that you really are picking out,
when you refer to me by the name
Shelly, namely, you know this thing,
can you imagine a world in which
that thing exists but the war.
But the thing that you're picking out
when you use the word Kagan does not exist
and that you can't do because
in the real world, of course,
Shelly and Kagan pick out just two
different names of this very same thing.
This thing right here. So imagining
a world in which Shelly exists,
but Kagan doesn't, or Kagan
exists. Shelly doesn't.
That's trying to imagine a world in
which you know I exist, but I don't.
And that's of course incoherent.
So if you can,
I'm going to hand contrast.
Can I imagine a world in which my left
hand exists but my right hand doesn't
easy. Why is it so easy? Because of course
there's two different things. Of course,
that doesn't mean that in the real world
one of them does exist in the other one
doesn't. But it does show that in the
real world there are two different things.
That's why I could imagine a
world with one but not the other.
Yeah.
Try to imagine a world in which somebody
smile exists but their body doesn't.
You can't do it.
You can't have the smile without the
body and of course no mystery about that.
That's because the smile isn't really
some separate thing from the body.
Talking about smiles, as we've noted
before, it's just a way of talking about,
you know, either what the body can do or
what a certain area of the body can do.
You can try to imagine it. You
know, in Alison Wonderland,
the Cheshire cat disappears
and all we have left.
The last thing that
disappears is the smile.
But of course when you imagine the
Cheshire cat only having the smile there,
you're still imagining the
cat's lips, teeth, maybe tongue,
whatever it is.
If you try to imagine a
smile with nobody at all,
can't be done. Why? Because the smile
isn't something separate from the body.
Try to imagine.
My mind says,
day card without my body easy from which
it follows that my mind and my body
must not be one thing.
They must in fact be two things.
That's why it's possible to
imagine the one without the other.
So this Cartesian argument seems to show
us that the mind is something separate
from distinct from not reduceable to
not just a way of talking about my body.
Yeah.
So it's gotta be something extra
above and beyond my body. It's a soul.
That's what Descartes argued.
As I say to this day,
philosophers disagree about
whether this argument works or not.
I don't think it does work.
And in a second I'll give you a conjurer
example and then having given the
counter example,
I mean that is what I'm going to give is
an example of an argument just like it
or at least an argument.
It seems to be just like it where we
can pretty easily see that that argument
doesn't work. And so something must go
wrong with Descartes' argument as well.
Well,
here's the counter example.
Okay.
Some of you,
I'm sure most of you,
maybe all of you are familiar
with the evening star.
The evening star is the roughly speaking
first heavenly body that's visible in
the sky as it gets dark,
at least at certain times of the year.
And I'm sure you're also familiar.
Then with the Morningstar,
the morning star is that heavenly body,
which is the last heavenly body that's
still visible as dawn comes in and begins
to get light. So as a first
pass, it's the evening stars,
the first star that's visitable.
And uh,
the morning star is the last
star that's visible, you know,
at the right times of the year.
Okay.
The world that we live in has both in
the evening star and the Morningstar.
Uh, but try to imagine a world
in which the evening star exists,
but the Morningstar does not seems
fairly straight forward. Right. You know,
I get up in the morning,
uh, at dawn's approaching,
I look around in the
Morningstar is not there.
There is no star where the Morningstar
had been or where people have claimed it
would be or something.
But the evening star still exist.
When I go out as, as sunsets and dusk
falls, there is the evening star. So it's,
it's a,
it's a trivial matter to imagine a world
in which the evening star exists in the
Morningstar does not. And so we've
got a, we could imagine that a, uh,
a day cart like argument saying,
if I can imagine the evening star
without the morning star that shows the
evening star in the Morningstar must
be two different heavenly bodies.
But in fact,
that's not so the evening star and the
morning star are the very same heavenly
body. In fact, it's not a
star at all. So it's a planet.
It's a venous,
if I recall correctly.
So look, there's only one thing.
The evening star is Venus.
The Morningstar is Venus.
So they couldn't be a world in
which the evening star exists.
But the morning star doesn't cause that
would be a world in which venous exists
and Venus doesn't exist. And obviously
that's not possible. Of course,
what you can imagine is a world in which
venous isn't visible in the morning.
Still that's not a world in which
the Morningstar doesn't exist.
Given that what we mean by the
Morningstar is that heavenly object,
whatever it is that in this
world we pick out, you know,
at that time in the morning
and looking up at the sky.
Okay?
So when I refer to the morning star,
I'm talking about Venus,
whether or not I realize it's Venus.
When I talk about the evening star,
I'm referring to Venus, whether or not I
realize that Venus is the evening star.
So as long as Venus is around,
well there's the evening star,
there's the Morningstar,
there's Venus can't have a world in
which the Morningstar doesn't exist.
But the evening star does.
Although you could have a world in which
Venus doesn't show up in the morning,
still from the fact that I can
imagine the world in which you know,
I look around for the morning. There it
isn't. I look around for the evening star.
There it is.
You might've thought that showed,
didn't Descartes prove to us that that
shows the evening star in the Morningstar
are two different things?
Well, no, obviously it didn't.
So let's think about what that
means. So, so we've got this argument
that they cart puts forward.
I can imagine my mind without my body
and Descartes says that shows that in
fact, my mind is something
separate from my body.
Well, I can imagine the evening
star without the Morningstar.
So son of Descartes,
you know,
they Cartson uh, has to say, oh,
so that shows that the morning starting
the evening star two different things,
but they Cartson would be wrong when
he says that the morning starting the
evening star are two different
things there. Just one thing,
namely Venus. In fact, the sentence,
they are one thing slightly misleading,
right? It's just one thing. Venus,
if that argument,
if the argument,
if trying to run the Cartesian
argument for astronomy fails
yet it seems to be an
exactly analogous argument,
we ought to conclude that
the argument for them,
the distinctness of the mind
and the body must fail as well.
Now that seems to me to be right.
I think the Cartesian argument does fail.
And I think the example of the
evening star in the morning star,
which is not at all original to me,
that this example shows this Kadra
example shows that Descartes' original
argument doesn't work either. At least
that's how it seems to me. Well, as I,
as I say, there are philosophers
are say, no, no, that's not right.
Maybe somehow we've misunderstood how the
argument goes and it doesn't. Exactly,
although these two arguments
seemed parallel, they're
not in fact parallel there,
there there's some subtle differences that
if we're not looking carefully, we'll,
we'll, we'll overlook. But God,
as I said, the debate goes on.
One of the reasons for thinking it's not
clear whether the argument fails or not
is because it's hard to pin down
where exactly did it go wrong?
Look, take, take, uh, take
the argument of the, uh,
the of the planets. You know, the, the
Morningstar in the evening star example,
I take it that we all agree that when
we attempt to run the Cartesian argument
in terms of the morning star,
the evening star, it fails.
But it's harder to say what went wrong.
How did it go wrong?
Why did it wrong? What are
the possibilities? Well,
we said, look, first claim,
first premise. I can imagine a world and
with in which the evening star exists,
but the Morningstar doesn't.
Well,
I suppose one possible response would be,
you know, you couldn't really do that.
You thought you were imagining a world
in which the evening star exists and the
morning star doesn't,
but you weren't really imagining a world
in which the evening star exists in the
morning star. Doesn't you miss
describe what it is you've imagined?
Well, that's, that's a silly thing
to say about the astronomy case.
Maybe that's the right diagnosis.
Could we similarly say,
I didn't really imagine a
world in which my mind exists,
but my body doesn't.
That little story I told last time I
thought I was describing a world in which
my mind exists. My body doesn't,
but it wasn't really imagining.
A world like that doesn't
seem so persuasive over there
did seem as though I was
imagining it.
What else could go wrong with
the uh, astronomy example? Well,
maybe I did imagine a world in which the
Morningstar exists and the evening star
doesn't exist.
But maybe imagining,
does it mean it's possible?
Normally we think if we imagine something,
it means it's possible here. I don't
mean of course empirically Po, yeah,
I can imagine a world with Unicorns.
It doesn't mean I think unicorns
are physically possible.
All we mean here is logically possible.
I can imagine a world with Unicorns seems
to follow that Unicorns are logically
possible. Imagination seems
to be a guide to possibility,
but maybe not always.
Maybe sometimes we can imagine
something that's really impossible.
Hmm. Try to imagine what can you
do that? Can't you not do that?
Try to imagine a round square.
Can you imagine it?
Can you not a man in certain moods?
I sort of feel I can just
begin to imagine it in.
Of course it doesn't really mean it's
possible. It seems like it's impossible.
So maybe imagination is a
flawed guy de possibility.
So maybe that's what we should say
about the mind body case. Yeah.
I can imagine a world
in which my mind exists,
but my body doesn't. But that doesn't
show that it's really possible,
logically possible to have a world in
which my mind exists is my body doesn't.
Maybe that's where the argument goes
up wrong or the hand isn't imagination.
Our best guide to logical
possibility isn't the reason.
I think unicorns are logically coherent
just because I can imagine them so
easily.
Another possibility.
Maybe we should say the mere fact that
it's possible for a and B to be separate
for a to exist without beef,
for that's clearly where they're separate.
The mere fact that it's possible for
them to be separate doesn't mean that in
the actual world they are separate.
Maybe the argument goes wrong by assuming
that identity when when a is equal to
B, it's always equal
to be, no matter what,
maybe identity as philosophers like to
put it. Maybe identity is contingent.
Maybe
a could be the same thing as B
in this logically possible world,
but we could imagine a
completely different logically
coherent world in which a
was not the same thing as B.
Okay.
If that's right, then maybe the
conclusion should be, well, you know,
uh, yeah. The,
the Cartesian thought experiment shows
that there could be a world in which
there are mines that are not identical,
the bodies,
but that doesn't mean that in this
world the mind is not identical to it.
To my body. Maybe in this world,
minds and bodies are identical.
Even though in other logically possible
worlds, the identity comes apart.
Identity is not necessary but
contingent as the philosophers put it.
It's not clear that that's right either.
The notion of contingent
identities very puzzling after all,
if if a really is B, how could they come
apart? There's only one thing there.
There's nothing to come apart. There's
just a equals B, that single thing.
What's to come apart,
so,
so where exactly does
the argument breakdown?
Is it that I'm not really imagining,
I'm just thinking, I'm imagining,
is it that imagination is not
really a good guide to possibility?
I just often it is, but not always
is it that identity is contingent.
The interesting thing about Descartes'
argument is that it's easy to see
something God has gone wrong in the
case of the morning star in the evening
star,
but it's difficult to pin
down what exactly went wrong.
Different philosophers agree that
something's gone wrong in the Morningstar
Morningstar in the evenings,
dark case,
but disagree about the best diagnosis
of where the mistake went in.
Okay.
Armed with your pet diagnosis of
where the argument goes wrong there,
you got to ask, does it also go
wrong in the mind and body case?
Yeah,
well, we could spend more
time, but I'm not going to.
I think Descartes' argument fails.
I think the Morningstar evening star
case shows us that arguments like this at
the very least,
can't be taken at face value just because
it looks as though we can imagine it
and just because it's seems as often
the fact that we can imagine one without
the other.
It just won't necessarily fall that
we really do have two things that are
separate and not identical
in the real world.
Okay.
I'd be happy to discuss with you, you
know, outside class at greater length.
My favorite theories as
to where the argument goes
wrong and why I think it goes
wrong and Descartes' case as well.
But I,
but I suggest that the argument
goes wrong. It's not, it's not.
It's not right.
And so Descartes' attempt to establish
the distinctness of the mind,
the than the immateriality of the mind
on the basis of this Cartesian thought
experiment. I think that's unsuccessful.
Well, we've spent, let's, let's,
let's step back and think
of where we've been.
We spent the last week and a half or so,
maybe a bit more,
two weeks talking about arguments
for the existence of the soul.
And unsurprisingly,
since I announced this was going to be
the result before the class had barely
gotten started,
I don't think any of these arguments work.
I believe the attempts to establish
the existence of a soul and in material
object, that house of consciousness
separate and distinct from the body.
I think those arguments fail.
But I recognize that this is something
that reasonable people can disagree
about.
And so this is as well be many times the
case over the course of the semester.
Something that I invite you to
continue to reflect on for yourself.
If you believe in a soul,
what's the argument for it?
Well,
what we're about to turn two is Plato's
discussion of these issues in the
dialogue. The Thedo, which
as I told you last week,
purports to lay out the final
days discussion with soccer.
Socrates before he is killed by
bee kills himself by drinking,
uh, the hemlock in
accordance with the, uh,
the punishment that's been given to him.
Okay?
Now in the course of this discussion,
Socrates and his disciples argue about
not so much the existence of the soul,
but the question really is the
immortality of the soul after all,
even if you believe in a soul,
as I remarked previously,
that doesn't give us yet any reason to
believe the soul continues to exist after
the death of your body.
The kind of dualist position that we are
considering in this class is an
interaction just position where the sole
commands the body. That's what
makes my fingers move right now.
And the body can affect the soul.
If I poke my body,
I feel it in my mind.
So the mind,
the soul and the body are obviously very
tightly connected and so it could be
even if the soul is something separate
from the body, then when the body dies,
the soul dies as well.
That's the question that's driving
the discussion in the Fito.
Do we have any good reason to believe
the soul survives the death of the body
and more particularly still do we have
good reason to believe it's immortal?
Okay.
Soccer. Socrates believes in
the immortality of the soul,
and so he tends to defend this position
justify to his disciples who are worried
that it may not be true. It's
important too, to realize as you,
as you read the dialogue,
it becomes fairly apparent that there
isn't so much any defense of the belief in
the soul. There's some of it, but it's
not the primary goal. For the most part,
the existence of the soul is just
taken for granted in the dialogue.
Plato's a dualist portray
Socrates as being a dualist,
and that's just taken for granted.
The question that the
philosophical discussion turns
on is not is there a soul,
but rather does it survive
the death of the body?
Is it immortal? Now, as I said,
this is Socrates,
his last day on earth,
and you'd expect him to be pretty bummed.
You'd expect him to be sad,
and one of the striking things is that
Socrates is in a very happy indeed,
jovial mood, joking with his, his friends.
Why is that? Well, of course
it's because he thinks,
first of all there's a soul and
it will survive and it's a mortal,
but more importantly still. Oh
really? Yeah, those are all crucial,
but there's an extra ingredient as well.
He thinks he's got good reason
to believe when he dies,
he's going to go basically
what we call heaven.
He thinks there's a realm you're
populated by sort of good,
God's and maybe other philosophical
kindred souls and, and if sort of you,
if you got your stuff
together here on life,
you'll get to go to that when you die.
And so he's excited,
he's pleased.
Why does he think he's going to go?
Well,
in thinking about Socrates is
belief in the existence of a soul.
It's important to understand is important
to notice that his take on which stuff
gets assigned to the body.
You know what have a bodily things
versus what are the sole like things is
rather different from the way I think
most of us nowadays would draw the line.
When I talked about
arguments for the existence
of a soul, I said, look, here's one
possible argument. I see colors.
No physical object could, no purely
physical Africans could see colors.
I can taste tastes and have this and
the smell of coffee and so forth,
but Socrates thinks all
those bodily sensations,
that's all stuff that
the body takes care of.
So unlike those modern dualist who
think we need to appeal to something
immaterial in order to explain bodily
sensations, Socrates thinks, no, no.
The body takes care of
all the bodily sensations,
all the desires and the wanting things
and the emotions and the feelings and the
cravings. That's all.
That's all bodies stuff.
What the soul does.
Socrates thinks there's soul thinks.
This soul in its essence is rational.
It takes care of the
thinking side of things.
What does the soul think about?
Well,
it's all things about all sorts
of things. Doubtless, you know,
but one of the things that it can do,
one of the things that sort of provides
the underpinnings as we'll see for
Plato's arguments for the
immortality of the soul,
it's the soul can think about,
well,
here I have to introduce a
word of philosophical jargon.
Sometimes the idea that sometimes
the term is called ideas.
Sometimes the term is called forms,
but the thought is that the soul can
think about certain pure concepts or ideas
like justice itself or beauty itself
or goodness itself or hell itself.
So to explain all this we need now,
I'll sort of crash course
in Plato's metaphysics.
Okay.
Obviously this will be rather superficial.
Those of you who would
like to know more about it,
I recommend reading more platonic
dialogues or taking a class in ancient
philosophy.
But here's the basic idea.
There's all sorts of beautiful
objects in the world.
Objects can vary in terms
of how beautiful they are.
The Plato's got the idea that there is
nothing in this world that perfectly
beautiful and yet for all that
we can think about beauty itself.
Well,
we might put it this way.
You might say ordinary humdrum everyday
physical objects are somewhat beautiful.
They're partially beautiful as
sometimes Platonists put it,
they participate in beauty,
they partake of beauty to varying degrees,
but none of them should be confused
with beauty itself or take justice.
There are various arrangements,
social arrangements that can be
just or unjust to varying degrees,
but we don't think anywhere in the world
there any society that's perfectly just
yet for all that the mind can think about.
Perfect justice and and
notice how ordinary empirical
social arrangements fall
short of perfect justice.
So whatever perfect justice is,
it's not one more thing
in the empirical world.
It's something we can think about.
It's something that things
in the empirical world can
participate in or partake
of to varying degrees,
but we shouldn't confuse
the physical things,
which can be just the people who can be
virtuous to one degree or another with
perfect virtue or perfect justice.
That's something that only the mind can
think about that we don't actually have
in the world.
The empirical world itself
or take being round the mind can
think about perfect circularity.
No physical object is perfectly circular.
They're only thing that are circular
to a greater or lesser degree.
So by thinking about it,
by thinking about these kinds of issues,
we can see that the mind has
some kind of handle on these.
Perfect. Well, we need
a word, and as they say,
Plato gives us the word ideas. Sometimes
it's translated as ideas or forms.
These things that we can think about
that are the sort of the template or at
least the standard or or,
or maybe at the very least,
it's that which the ordinary humdrum
things can participate in to varying
degrees. Perfect justice,
justice itself, beauty itself,
goodness itself, circularity
itself, health itself.
All of these things are well
as as plus goes nowadays,
call them platonic forms.
Oh,
ordinary material objects of this world
can partake of the various platonic
forms, but they should not be
confused with the platonic forms.
But we still,
even though we don't bump into
the platonic forms in this world,
we can think about them.
Our mind has a kind of grasp of them.
Of course.
The problem is we're,
we're distracted by
the comings and goings,
the hurly burly of the,
of the ordinary everyday world.
And so we don't have a very good grasp
of the platonic forms were able to think
about them,
but we're distracted.
What the philosopher tries to do,
this is Socrates is thought or Plato's
thought that he puts in Socrates.
His mouth with the philosophy tries to
do is free himself from the distractions
that the body poses,
the desire for food,
the craving for sex,
being concerned about pain.
All this stuff get, you know,
dry Hungary and after pleasure,
all this stuff gets in the way of
thinking about the platonic forms.
What the philosopher tries to do then
so as to better focus on these ideal
things is to sort of disregard the body,
put it aside,
separate his mind as
much as possible from it.
That's what Socrates says
he's been trying to do.
And so because of that,
he's got a better handle
on these ideal forms.
And then he believes when death comes in,
the final separation occurs
of the mind and the body.
His mind gets to go up.
His soul gets to go up to
this sort of heavenly realm.
Philosophers nowadays
called Plato's heaven.
Let's go to Plato's heaven where he can
sort of have more direct contact with
these things with the forms.
Now
I don't have the time here to say
enough to try and make it clear why this
platonic metaphysical view is a view
that not only is worth taking seriously,
but you know to this day,
many,
many philosophers think that at least
in its basic strokes, must be right,
but let me at least give you one
example that may give you a feel for it.
Think of math,
I think of some simple mathematical
claim like two plus two equals four.
When we say that two plus two equals four
or are we a two plus three equals five
we're saying something about numbers
that our mind is able to grasp,
but what are numbers anyway?
They're certainly not physical objects.
It's not as though some day you're
going to open up an issue of national
geographic and where the cover story is
going to be at long last explorers have
discovered the number two,
right?
It's not as though the number two is
something that you see or hear or taste or
could bump into whatever
the number two is.
It's something that our mind can grasp
but isn't actually in the physical world.
Okay.
That is the platonic take on mathematics.
There are numbers.
The mind can think about them.
Things can sort of partake of them.
If I were to hold up two pieces of paper,
there's a sense in which they
are participating in two hood,
but of course this is
not the number two here.
If I were to rip these pieces of paper,
I wouldn't be destroying the number two.
So the number two, the number was three,
whatever it is, whatever they are,
are these platonic abstract entities that
don't exist in space and time yet for
all that the mind can think about them.
That's the idea and it's not a
silly idea. I mean it's, it's,
it seems like a very compelling account
of what's going on in mathematics.
What mathematicians are doing is using
their mind to think about these platonic
ideas of mathematics to Plato's
thought was everything is like that.
It's not just math,
but justice itself is like that.
There are Josta unjust things in the
world. The mind can think about them,
but justice itself,
this sort of perfect I this
idea of being perfectly just,
that's something the mind can think about,
but it's not here in the world.
It's another abstract platonic form.
So that's the picture.
Plato's idea is that
if we start doing enough metaphysics,
we can see there must be
this realm of platonic ideas,
platonic forms,
and we can see that we are able
to grasp them through the mind.
This can't be a job the body does
because the body's only got it's bodily
capacities, right? It's able
to do the five senses thing.
It's the soul that thinks
about the platonic forms.
Okay.
And as Plato's than glad
to go on to try to argue,
given this picture of
what the mind can do,
he thinks he can persuade
us that the mind,
the soul not only survives
the death of your body,
but will last forever.
It's, it's, it's perfect.
It's immaterial, and, and,
and, and can't be destroyed.
It's a mortal.
So he offers a series of
arguments for that conclusion, uh,
for that position. And
starting next time, you know,
we'll work our way
through those arguments.